son días de buen clima en la argentina
el verano se siente en estas playas pero
en medio de un panorama preocupante en
lo que a la pandemia se refiere en los
últimos días los contagios diarios se
han más que duplicado en el país para
afrontar esta situación este viernes el
gobierno central restringe la movilidad
en la noche según el número de casos
registrados en los últimos 14 días los
gobernadores y gobernadoras cuando estén
en con estos riesgos epidemiológicos
deben tomar medidas relacionadas a la
restricción de circulación oa la
restricción de actividades adaptadas
naturalmente a su realidad adaptadas
naturalmente a sus costumbres y a sus
horarios al igual que europa américa
latina tiene ahora la preocupación
añadida de la nueva variante británica
del comit este viernes perú confirmó la
detección de la rama en una persona de
lima que no había viajado al extranjero
la nación inca se une a otros países
como chile o brasil que también
confirmaron la presencia de esta
variación y brasil- un día después de
haber superado los 200.000 fallecidos
reveló esta placa
de río de janeiro en honor a aquellos
que se llevó la pandemia este viernes el
país supera otro umbral más de 8
millones de contagios